Our 11th harmonics attached slash included in my personal programs,
preset frequencies, or are they only in other pathogen killing points?
So there is on the atelier rabbit is the only, so if you have a true right this doesn't exist,
this doesn't exist, but only atelier rabbit we can run 11th harmonics.
And originally I wrote a set of pathogen programs that are in the folder that says 11th harmonic pathogen kill programs.
Well, those are just common pathogen kill programs in that folder.
In the alphabetic listed of all the programs that are in there, all of them that it's relevant to have an
11th harmonic is written in 11th harmonic. I wrote every single one of those programs. So
if it if I believe that it would have been beneficial to have 11th harmonic, okay, if you're
running something that I'd say an inflammation program, there's not really any benefit to run
the 11th harmonic in inflammation, so that isn't written in the 11th harmonic. But if it's any type
of pathogen kill or a cancer program, then it's written in the 11th harmonic, so you don't have to
use that folder. And yes, all your personal preset frequencies are all in the 11th harmonic.
So because we're talking to kids people with cancer, so you have a diagnosis cancer, your cancer program
is written in the 11th harmonic. And remember if you have an atelier rabbit and you wouldn't be
asking this question if you did. But if you also have a true right, you cannot use these programs on
your true right. Personally, they won't work. But if you had an older true right with let's say version
five, they could possibly work with you, you're going to burn out on sheet. So with version 6.4,
they won't run. But with a version six or earlier, they may run, you're just going to you're just
going to fry the sheet. So it won't work. So the two machines are not compatible program wise. So
you can't run true right programs on the atelier rabbit, but how can you run the atelier rabbit
programs on the true right.